- Well, good afternoon everyone.
We're really pleased
to have next one of our deans
invited lecture series here.
Today we have Bratin Saha from Amazon AWS.
This series really is
intended to emphasize
the opportunities for connections
between the School of Engineering
and Yale and industry.
And our conversations today with Bratin
have really driven home that point.
We've been jumping from topic to topic,
all kinds of different ways,
that what's going on at
the university interrelates
and can impact what's going on at Amazon
and certainly vice versa.
Part of the infrastructure
that Bratin has been responsible
for developing at Amazon
is really the backbone
that will power the transformative tools
that we're witnessing
in industry right now
with generative AI.
This is a massively
computationally rich area,
but also a massively
computationally expensive
and data driven area.
So what I hope we'll learn today
is sort of ways that he
sees a future interaction
between Yale and Amazon,
being productive and
profitable for all of us.
So with that, I would love to welcome.
So I will say, Bratin was I think,
Zhong Shao's first PhD student.
Is that correct?
Yeah, so Zhong was the
chair of computer science,
certainly, the whole time
I've been here until this year
and it's really wonderful to see
these birds that have taken flight,
come back home to roost
(both laughing)
and share their experiences with us.
So he's going to give a introduction
and tell us a little
bit about his trajectory
and then he and I will have a brief chat
and then you guys can
ask him some questions.
Okay. So with that, take it away.
Thank you, Dean Brock. Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- It's nice to be back home.
You know, I spent a lot of time,
a lot of days and nights at
the A.K. Watson in the zoo
and other places
and it was really nice to see
how the university has evolved
over the last many years,
thanks to leadership
from Dean Brock, the Yale
leadership, John himself,
and seeing the amount of investments
that are being made in computer
science and engineering.
So what I want to talk
about today is some ways
in which we have been using generative AI
and enabling customers in the enterprise
to use generative AI.
Today, most of the machine learning,
vast majority of machine learning
and AI in the world happens on AWS,
happens on the infrastructure
that my team builds.
And what I wanted to talk about
and where I'm hoping you
can get some insights on
is where the industry is going
and what would be the research problems
that would be interesting,
especially from an industry perspective,
where the science sees,
in terms of where we can
take it out to customers
and where the science isn't in
terms of where I think there's
a lot of fundamental research
to be done in a university like Yale.
So let me get started.
So, there really have been
a set of tipping points
around generative AI.
One of them has been just
the astonishing increase
in the amount of compute capability.
If you think about IT, if you
think about computer science,
it was driven by Moore's law.
And Moore's law said
that the amount of
compute is going to double
every 18 months.
What we have seen in
AI and machine learning
for the last 10 years
is that compute capacity has been doubling
every three and a half months.
We are going at six
times, literally six times
the speed of Moore's law.
We are going literally
at six times the speed
at which IT used to go.
And IT evolved really, really fast.
Even if you look at the last five years,
that's about 30 years
of progress in IT land.
And now you go back 30
years, there was no Amazon,
no Google, no Facebook, no
Meta, no Twitter and so on.
So this field is moving extremely fast.
The other thing that has happened,
is the emergence of internet scale data,
and I'll give you a little bit of insight
into what that is doing
with large language models.
And then the third thing that has happened
is the amount of machine
learning innovation.
And on the next slide I'm going
to talk to you about this.
But the other thing that has also happened
that I think is really interesting
for Yale as a university,
for students and faculty here
is the role of the cloud.
Because what we have done
is we have made it possible
to make this compute and
this data readily available
to anybody that wants to use
it at a very, very cheap cost.
So what has this meant for innovation?
If you think about machine learning,
the capacity of machine learning models,
and you can measure it
by a number of parameters
just in the last three
years has grown by 1600x.
This is super, super, super exponential.
And that is what is driving
amazing innovations.
Now what does that mean
from a data perspective?
If you think about we humans,
in the course of a lifetime,
an average human, we'll probably listen
to about a billion words
or 2 billion words.
When we train these foundation models,
we train them on trillions of words.
So each one of these foundation
models is being trained
thousands of times of data
that an average human will
be consuming in the lifetime.
If I give you another perspective on this,
all of Wikipedia is about 18
gigabytes, 18 to 20 gigabytes.
When we train these models,
we train them on trillions
of terabytes of data.
And that means that you're
putting in the knowledge
of thousands of Wikipedias
into one of these models.
And that is what is triggering
this amazing innovation
that is coming on in generative AI.
Now, there's a lot of research to be done,
in terms of making it really deployable
at scale in the industry
and some of that is what
I'm going to talk about.
So this innovation can
transform industries,
it will transform industries.
And I'll give you a little bit of sense
of some of the places
where we are doing this.
So let me start with Amazon CodeWhisperer.
This is a software development tool
that is based on generative AI.
We have seen a lot of companies
now start using this tool.
So let me actually show
you how this works.
So all you are doing is, as a programmer,
you are just writing comments,
you're just putting in
English language text.
So the programmer came in and said,
"Just a write me a program
to upload a file from S3,
using server side encryption."
Then CodeWhisperer
actually takes this command
and then CodeWhisperer
is just going to come in
and generate this file by itself.
This is all automatically generated.
As a programmer, you just have
to write this English stuff
and then CodeWhisperer will
give you a few hints about it
and then you come in and
this is another Java thing,
and all you're doing
is, you're writing this,
it went too fast, it
said, "Create some stuff,"
And CodeWhisperer is
going to basically create
the entire function for you.
And what we have seen,
so this is what that programmer writes,
"Create a function to do this."
And it'll generate the
entire function for you.
And then you can go in
and run some checks
and so on and so forth.
So what does that mean?
What does this mean for the
software development industry
and what does it mean for
a university like Yale?
We have studies that show people
that are using CodeWhisperer-like tools
are about 50% more productive
than people who don't,
because you're not doing your own coding.
But there's something
more profound going on,
and these tools, by the way,
are going to keep getting
better every year.
So imagine five years from now,
when these tools are really good.
What is going on is
something very profound here.
It's that Java and Python and Rust
are no longer the programming languages.
English is the new programming language.
And you can imagine that we
are going to be able to do this
with say, Italian or Chinese
or Hindi or something.
And so our mother tongues
become the new programming language.
What does this mean for Yale?
How should computer science
teaching evolve to address this?
And I was talking in fact this morning
with Dean Brock about how do you bring
more liberal arts education to STEM,
to computer science and engineering?
But this may basically mean
that anyone who is an English major
or history major, whatever,
is now going to become
a software developer,
five years, ten years from now.
And so when you have
democratized this to some extent,
what does it mean for
innovation in the world
when every person is a software developer?
And these are I think things
that a university like Yale
should think about, because
it's really kind of a university
that's at the forefront of,
how does technology impact society
five to ten years from now
and how do we educate people
in that way?
The next one I'll talk about
is what's happening in medicine.
So there is a lot of work
we are doing in my team
and elsewhere in terms of
applying AI to medicine.
And the reason that is
happening as you can see,
just like with Moore's Law,
the cost of sequencing a
human genome is dropping
in a very fundamental way.
It used to be a huge amount,
few million, hundreds of
millions, 20 years back,
to now it's about $200.
And because this cost has
dropped so dramatically,
you can now spurn an entire
industry that's based on this.
In fact, so we have these challenges,
in terms of being able
to do genomic sequencing
and as a result of that,
I was actually talking
to someone yesterday,
yesterday at dinner, who
is at Columbia University,
and they were actually talking
about, "Hey, we also want,"
and I'm sure the same thing is true here
in the school of medicine
or even in the engineering departments
that are trying to do some AI in medicine,
that you have a lot of
infrastructure issues
you have to deal with,
if you want to do that
kind of genomic sequencing.
That is why we came out with this service
that is actually being used
by a lot of universities
and public health departments now,
to be able to do gene sequencing
and precision medicine.
And in fact, the Department
of Public Health in Chicago,
they were able to use these
tools to run some analysis
and they found that when
you go like 10 miles
from downtown Chicago,
your life expectancy falls
by like eight or ten or twelve years.
And the reason that happens
is because of difference in access
to specific kinds of care.
And they were able to do that,
because they were able to use these tools
to see what kind of medical
care isn't being afforded there
and they have now changed
the way that medical care is being given.
You know, similarly, Genomics England,
they have a huge database of,
probably the world's largest,
of humans who have genetic mutations
with some rare diseases,
and they're now using these tools
to do a lot of precision medicine.
And I do think that medicine is a domain
that is ripe for a lot of innovation,
from computer science, from
AI and a lot of other fields.
I'll give you another example
of the kind of innovation that we can do.
So patients today are
walking with tons of data.
You have all of your wearables
and you're getting all kinds of data
from multiple different data sources.
But the thing is, 97% of this
data is not being analyzed,
it's not being used.
And so imagine the quality
of patient outcomes
that we could improve
if there's a way for us to
be able to analyze this data.
And this, being able to analyze this data,
I think is another really
interesting research
that I think a university like Yale
would be perfectly suited for.
Because you have a school
of medicine, that's a leader
and you have the engineering
parts, that's a leader,
you have the data science
parts, that's a leader.
And so this kind of interdisciplinary work
would just be amazing,
in terms of improving patient outcomes.
Now, there's one way in
which we are doing this,
which is clinical documentation.
So today, when you go to a physician,
because of electronic health records,
that interaction that you're
having with the physician
needs to be scribed.
And so the physicians
are actually doing it
and then creating a summary
and then they're uploading it
to your electronic health records.
It turns out physicians
in the US, on average,
spend about 40% of the
time doing the scribing.
And that is the time
that is not being spent
on patient care,
that's the time that is
really an unproductive use
of the physician's time.
And so what we have done,
and we have launched this
product a little bit,
is using generative AI
to automatically generate these
patient physician summaries.
So as you're talking to a physician,
that particular conversation
is getting captured,
it's automatically getting transcribed.
A generative AI model is automatically
generating the summary.
Now, the key innovation that we did here,
that I think is very relevant also
from a research point of view,
is as you know, generative AI
can also have hallucinations.
So you need to have a very
high degree of accuracy.
And so one of the things that we did here,
which I think was a pretty
nice piece of innovation,
but there's a lot more
research to be done,
is what's called the concept of grounding.
So we have the original
transcript, we create a summary,
but every part of that summary,
we put a link to the
original source that says,
"Here is why I created the summary."
And that is what helps make
this deployable to enterprises.
This is supposed to reduce
the scribing time by 70%.
We are partnering with 3M,
who have 300,000 physicians across the US.
Now imagine reducing the time
of making them more productive by 70%
for 300,000 physicians in the US.
In fact, I was looking
at all of the places
that this will go into POC,
and I was really glad to know
that Yale New Haven Hospital
is actually one of them.
And the reason I go into this example,
is to say that you may be looking
at a lot of generative AI,
some of it may seem to be hype,
but a lot of it is actually
being put into real production
at scale deployment.
And so all of the
research that you can do,
in terms of making it accurate,
in terms of reducing hallucinations,
in terms of finding ways
to do the grounding,
actually helps in these situations.
So here is how it actually works.
I already talked about this.
So the patient says,
this one is not showing,
you can see the highlighted parts,
the patient says, "This
is what is going on."
And we take the whole summary
and then we create it.
And you're not seeing it here,
but we'll actually have links,
we'll actually have references from here,
that says, this part came from here,
this part came from here.
And all of this is being
automatically generated.
So what do you need to do
generative AI in the enterprise?
The first one is you really
want to have an easy way
of building with foundation models,
and you want to have a choice of building
with foundation models,
and the second is then infrastructure.
And that in both of these,
there's a lot of research to be done,
especially in the second one
and I'll talk a little bit on that.
So the first one was the kind
of models that you can use.
Because you use Bedrock,
there's a bunch of other stuff to use,
and I think the key thing
that comes out from a research perspective
is that it's very likely
that one model isn't
going to rule them all.
And so there is a need for figuring out
what kinds of models work
well in what situations.
And the thing that I think
will really distinguish
going forward is not just
the models but the data
that is being used to train them.
And in fact, that's where Dean Brock,
which is, can Yale play a role,
given the amount of data you
have across the university,
not just in the engineering
and in the social sciences,
in all of the libraries and all of this,
is there a role that Yale can play
in making that data
available as training data?
Because that would be huge
and that would not just be huge
from a research perspective
in moving frontiers,
but I think
that would be a huge source
of monetization as well,
if Yale could figure out how to do that.
So the first thing in
here is the set of models
and we have some of the
most state of the art models
that you can play with.
And then there are a lot more models
that are available on SageMaker Jumpstart.
Now foundation models
can do a lot of natural
language interaction with you,
but foundation models
cannot execute tasks yet
on your behalf.
So for example, let's say you said,
"Give me all of the
options for having a plane
fly to Florida over Thanksgiving."
Today they're probably going to give you
all of those options,
but then you would say,
"And by the way, go make
the bookings for me."
So that action part is still not there.
And that is why we
actually augmented Bedrock
with what we call agents,
where agents can take
actions on your behalf.
Now, there's a lot of research going on,
how do you make it safe?
How do you make it secure,
so it works in a particular
constrained set of environments,
constrained set of actions.
And so there's a lot of
research to be done here,
but you can clearly see that
is where the world is headed.
You can clearly see that
you're going to be having
some kind of a personal assistant
and say, "Hey, I need these to be bought.
Go get this from the web."
And so this notion of having
actions and assistance,
all of this is coming.
And so there's a lot of
really interesting research
to be done, in terms of
how do you secure it?
How do you ensure privacy of the data?
How do you ensure that
the actions being taken
are well-meaning? And so on and so forth
Okay, next,
let me start a little bit
around the infrastructure.
Most of this is on GPUs
and of course we have our
own custom silicon as well.
That's purpose built for generative AI
and there's just a ton of work to be done.
There's a ton of systems
research to be done
in making this more efficient.
Even now there's a lot
of investment to be done
in training these models.
And at every layer, at the hardware layer,
at the system software
layer, at the tooling layer,
there's a ton of innovation to be done
in terms of figuring out
how we make this a lot more efficient.
And we have some ideas,
but if people are looking for
interesting research ideas,
this is where there's a
lot of work to be done.
And then there is tooling.
What happens, and again, there's
a lot of HPC related stuff
that you can do here,
the thing that's different
about generative AI especially
is the scale of compute.
And so, as you're training,
let's say these foundation models,
you're probably training
them on thousands of GPUs
or other accelerators,
maybe for months at end.
And what then used to happen before was,
what about the resiliency
of the accelerator?
What if one of the accelerators
for some reason has an error?
How do you recover from it?
Because you don't want
to waste months of work.
And so, that is where things
like self-healing systems
that we have,
but you can obviously do more there
and other kinds of optimizations,
become really important.
And so for those of you working
the system software side,
this is really fertile territory
for the kind of innovations
that you can do in terms
of having real impact.
The other thing that's happening
is the emergence of no code tools.
There's no code software
and this is all about democratizing
and making software development accessible
to a lot more people.
So there's no code software tools
and then there's no code
machine learning tools.
And you and I mentioned,
before that generative AI
is going to democratize
software development,
like English will be the
new programming language.
These no code tools are also about,
how do I do point and
click to get my job done?
And this is yet another the trend.
When you think about product development,
having these I-aesthetics, A-aesthetics,
how do you make something
really simple to use?
How do you make something
really easy to use,
is not just about science education,
it also needs a lot of broad liberal arts
kind of an education,
so you really understand from a product.
You can think about a product,
not just from the
engineering point of view,
but also from the usability point of view.
How will users interact with it?
And I think that is one of the things,
again, that a university like Yale,
with its rich liberal arts tradition,
can do a really good job of.
How do you train engineers,
who not only know how to build a product,
but who can actually build a product
that's delightful to use
and delightful to use for
a lot of other people.
When you're talking about, how
do I develop a software tool
that someone who doesn't know anything
about software uses it.
And there's a lot of work
that has to go into designing that stuff.
So this is going to be another
trend that is important.
The reason I wanted to
talk about Amazon Monitron
is to show how there can be synergies
with what is already available
and how Yale can play into that.
Because there are some
strengths we bring at AWS,
but there are some strengths
where we are just not in the
domain, that Yale can bring.
So what Monitron does, is
it uses machine learning
for doing predictive
maintenance of your machines.
Like it predicts when
your machine may go down
and the way it does that
is we have these sensors
and these sensors are
monitoring your equipment
for temperature and vibrations.
And so, if you think of a machine,
when the machine is about to break,
it kind of sounds a little weird
or it vibrates a little weird,
it can get heated up
and so on and so forth.
So these sensors are put on
devices, put on machines,
and then they monitor the
temperature and vibrations
of these devices.
And then what we use is,
you'll see these in these kinds of things.
These sensors are installed
in these kinds of machines
and then they're
streaming it to the cloud.
And in the cloud we detect anomalies
and based on those anomalies,
we predict when something
is going to break.
And so there are a lot of
companies, this is Baxter,
but, Baxter, SKF,
and a bunch of other companies, Coke,
that are actually using these
for predicting when their
equipment will fail.
Now here's something interesting,
I was actually talking about this,
as I mentioned, I was
talking to some people
from the Yale School
of Medicine yesterday,
and they said, "Well, do
you have anomaly detection
that we could use to predict strokes?"
Now you can imagine this,
these sensors are actually
sending data to the cloud.
That is a time series data,
where we are predicting anomalies.
Now you can use those
predicting anomalies in our case
to detect when a machine
is going to break,
but you can imagine you can do this
for other kinds of time
series data as well,
one of which could be health data.
Now, where could AWS and
Yale play really well
with each other?
If you have to do this work
and if you have to do this research,
you need an infrastructure
that will be able to take data
from millions and billions of people,
be scalable, be robust and efficient
and do all of that anomaly detection.
We have that infrastructure here.
What someone else could do is say, "Look,
here is the domain expertise.
Here is what the data looks
like in a normal person.
Here is where the anomalies come in
when someone is going to fall sick."
So you could then marry
that domain expertise
with our infrastructure and
then together we could build
some really interesting things.
And by the way, I was talking to people,
and this is probably applicable
even to the school of engineering,
is we have similar things
for image processing.
So you can imagine that you
could have radiology images
being uploaded and detect anomalies.
Now there's two aspects to that.
You have to build
infrastructure, which we have,
and then someone has to do
the research that sits on top
and then together you end up
with some remarkable systems.
The other thing that
is coming across a lot
is sustainable mobility.
So if you look at the automotive industry,
that's really thinking
about electrification,
about getting greener, using batteries.
And so one of the things
that's happening now a lot
is using geospatial data
to figure out driving habits
and optimizing things.
So BMW has been working with us
and they do things like
predicting the impact of traffic,
where do you put charging stations?
And a lot of other stuff.
So all kinds of data analysis going on,
but this is yet another
modality to the data,
which is geospatial and how do I use it
for predicting user behavior.
And so, they're basically looking at this
for predicting affinity
for electric vehicles,
depending on driving tendencies
and where people do their drivings.
Okay. I talked about
all of the applications,
first about the rapid rate
at which science is going,
then about all of the applications,
then where there are still
research problems in doing that.
And then the fourth, this
one is yet another place
where there's a lot of
research to be done,
but a lot of interdisciplinary
research to be done.
Which again, knowing the heritage of Yale,
is a great place for Yale to be in,
because the spending on AI is
going to just go astronomical.
I mean, you can look at
all kinds of estimates.
Those estimates are always
hundreds of billions
or trillions.
So it's going to be a
pretty large industry.
But there's also a need to be
able to use it responsibly,
to be able to put in the right
amount of guardrails in it.
And that is what is not just
a computer science problem,
that's a computer science
with public policy,
there are legal implications of it.
And so that is a holistic thing
and I think that is where,
again, universities can play a big role,
especially in bringing
interdisciplinary work.
There's just a ton of research
that can be done here,
in terms of this is the core
computer science part of it,
in terms of fairness, bias
detection, toxicity and so on.
In terms of explainability,
why is the model behaving
the way it is behaving?
In terms of robustness,
how do you make it safer
from all kinds of injection attacks
and so on and so forth?
In terms of privacy, governance and so on.
So especially with generative AI,
especially with large language models,
there's a lot of work to be done in this,
but there's also a lot
of work, so we do this,
and if you want to get a sense
of what is useful to industry,
take a look at some of
these service cards,
because they talk about how
customers approach this problem
and how customers would
like to get insights
into these problems.
But it's just not there,
because there's a lot of work
on regulatory agencies now.
There's a regulation called ISO 40:2001
that is making its way through,
in terms of how you regulate
or how you work on AI and ML.
And that's all a great place
for a lot of interdisciplinary
work to be done,
that's going to have a huge impact
on how we deal with AI and ML.
Finally, I want to talk
about a couple of things
that we do in my team.
We also run the Amazon Research Awards
and we have awarded over $35
million in support of research.
And in the last, what, eight years,
we have funded more than 220 universities
in about 40 countries.
So it's a pretty global spread,
is actually funding
that we also do to Yale.
So I know that at this point
we have actually two grants going on.
One, with I think in
the genomics department
and the lower one
is probably in the computer
science department.
But this happens every year.
So if people have good
ideas, submit to these.
And in addition, because this
is getting so interesting,
we're also investing a
hundred million dollars
in helping customers take
generative AI projects
from concepts to production.
And so, these are all really
good areas to be focusing on,
in terms of your projects,
in terms of your research,
in terms of enabling things.
So that's all I have and
I'm happy to take questions,
but really the key
areas I would talk about
is foundation models
and there'll be a multiplicity of models,
there's some research to be done there.
The infrastructure, so we
can actually reduce the cost
by orders of magnitude, make
it much more accessible,
the kind of applications,
I talked about healthcare,
I talked about software development,
but, contact centers,
industrial manufacturing,
document processing, all of these
are going to get innovations.
And then finally, education and training.
There's actually a really
interesting work that showed,
this was done by BCG.
So we did work with Accenture
that showed if you use generative AI,
you become up to 50% more productive.
BCG did similar work,
they actually got similar
results in terms of productivity.
But one of the interesting insights
that came out of their research
was that for beginners,
the jump in productivity was much higher.
And so think of it as if you
are a new software engineer
going to a company, you take a long time.
In fact, I was talking
to Dean Brock about this,
like, we have this Amazon
universities and all that,
which is we are trying to get people up,
familiar with the infrastructure we have
and that's a long ramp up process.
Imagine if things are getting automated,
that becomes much easier.
So it's actually a great leveler,
in terms of how you up-skill employees.
Now, if generative AI is a great new tool
for up-skilling employees,
ultimately a university's
job is to up-skill society.
And so I think it's really
important for universities,
especially eminent universities like Yale,
to think about what would
up-skilling society,
up-skilling students 10 to
15 years from now look like?
And the question, and the thought
that I would leave you with,
is if Yale were founded
today, how would it be run?
How would all of these
technology be integrated
into how you operate?
Okay, that's all I have.
(audience clapping)
- Okay, thanks. Thanks so much, Bratin.
(audience murmuring)
So I think a question to this last point
that I would love to know,
is, so let's say we were
designing this new version of Yale
and one of the first
things we wanted to do
was to teach kind of a flagship course
called generative AI for, I
don't know, for undergraduates,
for non-majors or something like that.
What would be the
elements you would include
and how would you bring this
kind of larger population
into this sphere of, what I think,
people are a little worried about,
may be kind of seen as
exclusive in some way?
How do we bring everybody in?
- So I would look at it from two aspects.
One is a lot of content
creation will be assisted
by generative AI.
And so, let's say I am an artist
or I am someone that is writing drafts.
The first draft, a few years from now,
will probably be created by
a generative AI assistant,
that then you improve.
So the generative AI doesn't take away
the role of the human,
generative AI, at least 'till now,
doesn't have the creativity
that a human has.
But what it can get to,
is it can actually accelerate your work.
And so previously,
let's say you would have to create a draft
and you're thinking a long
time and you're writing it
and you're spending weeks over it,
it can probably accelerate
it to a couple of hours.
And that applies as much to the
non-engineering parts of it,
there's a lot of creative
output happening there.
And so the things that I would look at,
is how do you use it as an
assistant in daily work?
How do you try to maybe automate
some of the tedious work
that you do?
And how do you make sure that
people outside of engineering,
outside of computer science,
are aware of these tools
and are thinking about
how to integrate that
into their daily lives?
The way I look at it almost,
is this is like the
emergence of the internet
and today,
everybody outside of CS
and engineering uses email.
Like, email has become a
natural way of doing work.
Messaging and all this
has become a natural way
of doing work.
And so, how do you
integrate these technologies
into your way of working?
The difference with previous technologies,
the difference with
prior technical changes
is that prior technical changes
were not a creative assistant, right?
This is the thing that can get integrated
into the creative workflow
and that is where I think we
would also look to universities
to help us understand how
these should get integrated.
- So, like the emergence
of the calculator,
there was a lot of anxiety
about how this is going to change
the way we think about education.
The calculator has the virtue,
that it predictably gives
you the correct answer.
So there's a funny
phenomenon you mentioned,
which is AI hallucination,
and I think those of us
in science and engineering
are kind of particularly unnerved by this.
So you ask generative AI a question
that has to do with a research topic
and sometimes it just
gives you the wrong answer.
(Jeffrey laughing)
- And it gives sometimes
gives you that answer
in a very expert-like way.
- Exactly. It sounds
like the right answer.
What's your sort of response to that,
in terms of what you're
seeing in the research front?
Can we ameliorate that, can
we think about it in a way
that makes it sort of seem
like more of a bonafide research tool
for serious engineering?
- Yeah, so I think there's
a lot of research going on
in how you deal with that
and how you mitigate that.
There are techniques like RAG,
retrieval augmented generation,
that reduce it to a large extent.
Some of the grounding
things that say, "Okay,
I generated it, but I got it from here."
So it's kind of an accelerator.
You look at the output, you
don't completely rely on it,
but you can quickly check it.
And I think there's a lot
of research to be done.
This I think is a really good
area for fundamental research
and especially I think
even to a large extent
these neural nets are
still not fully understood,
how these are operating.
And I think that's a great
area for university research.
- So in terms of where,
you mentioned, sort of,
great institutions like Yale,
of course we're all big fans of Yale,
but where do you see our
comparative advantage
in this space, in terms
of preparing students
to enter this kind of new,
I mean really novel,
transformed workforce?
- I think there are a couple of aspects.
One is, Yale has some of the
best research and teaching
and professors across a variety of fields.
And a lot of this,
applying AI to healthcare,
requires collaboration between people
who know medicine deeply
and people who know
computer science deeply
and people who know engineering deeply
because you are doing
these sensors and so on.
There's a lot of implications
on society and public policy.
One of the examples that
I would love to see,
and we would love to collaborate on that,
is there are customers who say,
"I have all kinds of legal contracts
that I sign with everyone.
Can you quickly,
if I upload three or four
of these legal contracts,
can you quickly tell me
if there are conflicting
portions in there?"
And so an interaction with the law school
and someone from the
computer science department
would be great.
Public policy is ripe for this.
So I think one of the things
that Yale can really do
is that interdisciplinary portion.
And then the second part,
which I a think university
like Yale can do,
that's probably generally
true of a lot of universities,
but I think more true of Yale,
because Yale has this really
strong theoretical foundation
to everything that it has done,
is really furthering the understanding
at a theoretical basic level
of what is going on with
some of these neural nets.
And as you were saying Dean Brock,
I think there's a lot of need
to get into the system side
because when you get into the system side,
you're truly impacting
society and shaping products.
But I think without losing
that core theoretical strength,
because someone has to do that for us
to really truly understand these systems.
- Alright, well very good.
I think I've exhausted my
short list of questions,
but I know there must
be many in the audience.
Is there anyone who?
Okay, you're first hand
up, in the front row here.
Oh, here's comes mic.
- Oh, perfect. Hi, My
name's Neil Sagitava,
I'm an undergrad,
studying computer science.
I actually interned at AWS this
past summer in Santa Clara.
So good to meet you as as my boss.
(all laughing)
My question, which I got
asked by family and friends
for the past few months,
was where is AWS in the conversation of,
where's AWS's chat GPT?
So maybe you could discuss,
and you mentioned in your roadmap earlier,
just highlight some of AWS's strengths
in that, moving forward.
- I think our key strength
is making systems fit
for enterprise usage.
Now, I won't say it's easy,
but it's one thing to get something out
that a lot of consumers can use,
but when you're thinking of an
about an enterprise setting,
you really have a very different
bar in terms of robustness,
in terms of accuracy
and so on and so forth.
And so now you're seeing,
I'll give you an example,
think of CodeWhisperer,
that I talked about.
You can, and other companies have,
come out with tools of,
here is how you use
generative AI for software.
We came out with CodeWhisperer
and a lot of our time was spent
in putting accurate license attribution.
So what you do, is when
you're generating code,
you have to make sure
it is not a copy paste
of somebody else's code.
And if that's somebody else's
code has a proper license,
you've got to be able to generate code
that has that copyright attribute.
We were the first to come out with,
here is software development
and here is the
appropriate license for it.
And if you don't have that,
you can use that for research projects
or just fun hackathons, you
cannot use that in industry.
So our core thing is how do you make
these appropriate and
suitable for industry?
And that I think is a core strength.
That is the place we innovate.
- That's great. That applies
to scientific research as well,
where you need appropriate
citations across the space.
Sorry, next question.
- Thank you for an amazing talk.
Yes, thank you Bratin for an amazing talk.
I'm Sam Hayek, I'm a fellow
in one of the Yale colleges.
Five, ten years from now,
Amazon will need to
differentiate its AI products
to compete with, let's say the Microsofts
and the other competitors
and one way obviously, is to
make the products user friendly
and so on and so forth.
I'm concerned about,
not for Amazon itself but all the players,
about the integrity of
the fundamental data.
Could you give us examples
of how you ensure integrity?
Yeah, very simply make sure
that, let's say the image,
one of the images that you're
feeding into the ML system
is not corrupt and is not
giving the wrong results.
- Yeah, I'm glad you asked that question,
because that's something
that's top of mind for us.
And integrity, security, privacy,
this is just foundational
to everything we do,
not just AI and ML
and we have whole teams
that are focused on that.
So we have a lot of mechanisms for that,
one of the things that pretty
much every service does is,
and we do in the AI space,
is end-to-end encryption of everything.
So you have encryption addressed,
encryption in transit with
customer provided keys.
So there's just no way anyone
can kind of access that data.
There are a bunch of
other mechanisms we use
in terms of ensuring privacy of the data
and we will also be coming
up with some innovations now
that actually reuse some
of the latest signs,
in terms of how you do that.
So this is pretty fundamental
to everything we are building.
One of the other things I'll also mention
that a lot of customers are
doing with generative AI
is they're saying, "Look, I have,"
I mean it could be Yale,
it could be a company.
I'll give you example.
So for example, we have a
pharma company, let's say,
that wants to use this generative AI
and enable its chemists.
And the way it wants
to enable its chemists,
is they want to be able to go in
and say, "Hey, give me
all of the experiments
that this company has
run in the last 10 years
about the side effects of this drug."
And today you have to
run a lot of searches
and now with you can
imagine with generative AI,
it can just find it out.
But the issue is that
that data is not public.
Only that company has it.
And so you need to be
able to customize models
with your own data.
Now, the way we do it,
kind of answers the previous question,
is pretty unique.
The way we do it, is when
you customize the model,
want to customize the model,
we actually create your own
private copy of the model
and then we create it in your
own virtual private cloud.
So it's in your own security domain.
So we have a lot of these
mechanisms that we are using
to ensure the security of the data.
- [Jeffrey] Good. Yep. Thanks.
- [Ben] Hi, I'm Ben,
I am an international
student in Yale College.
I would like to ask you,
which industries are least
likely to be affected by AI
in your opinion?
Because there is like a
debate on which occupations
which industries, which jobs,
are least likely to be affected
in your personal opinion
in the long term with AI.
- This, I think, is a
fundamental innovation
that ultimately will touch
every aspect of what we do.
And the way I look at it is,
it'll generate so much new stuff.
Net technology has been,
at least in my view,
net technology has been a
positive force for society,
a positive force for humanity.
We have become more
productive, we do a lot more.
And I think this is yet another
of those transformational technologies
that will do the same.
And I suspect just like the internet,
just like some of the key technical parts,
it's going to be integrated
into everything we do.
Ultimately, we humans create.
Ultimately we do some form of creation.
And this I think will
be an assistant in that.
- Next question.
- [Andrew] Andrew, office of development,
you mentioned using AI
to help with interactions
between patients and doctors.
I was wondering if you
foresee any unique roadblocks
with medicine with
privacy concerns or HIPAA,
anything like that
that may make it more
difficult to be incorporated?
- So the things that I mentioned
were all HIPAA compliant.
I think in medicine you
obviously have a much higher bar,
because you don't want it in situations
where the errors could be in there.
So the bar there will be higher,
and probably at least initially,
it'll be a lot more of an
assistant functionality,
where there's always a human in the loop
that is doing the checking
of the verification.
So let's say instead of a
human creating the whole thing
that took them an hour,
it'll probably be a human
verifying the output
and doing edits as needed,
that takes them 10 minutes.
So it's really going to
be a productivity enhancer
rather than a replacer.
- [Michael] Hi, I am Michael Cohen.
I'm a public citizen here
and there was an old
expression in computing,
"Garbage in, garbage out."
If you look at the data that's out there,
there's a lot of garbage out there.
How do you tell the difference
between like Newsmax
and the New York Times?
- Yeah! So there is a huge,
and I didn't go into that,
there is a lot of
engineering work we put in,
but there's a lot of science as well.
And there's actually two parts to this.
So when we train our models,
we have an entire team
that is curating the data.
So that's curating the data,
not just for the kind of content,
but also for things like
bias and toxicity and so on.
So you don't want to train the
model with inappropriate data
of all kinds. So that's one aspect of it.
And we have huge teams
that are working on that.
Like, lots of people whose job solely,
is to not just collect
the data but verify it.
But I also think there's a
lot of research to be done.
Now there's a second aspect of that
which is how do you use
the minimum amount of data
to get the desired outcome.
So there is a lot of work that shows
that if you had a better
way of curating your data,
you might be able to get the same result
with fewer training cycles.
So there's work to be done there
and I think there's work to be done,
there's a lot of research to be done
in how do you more efficiently
curate these data sources.
So today it's a pretty, not a pretty,
it's a very labor intensive effort
and that, in many situations
is when we are training
these large language models.
In many situations that
data collection and curation
and filtering effort is
actually the larger bottleneck.
- That's another good role
for discerning Yale
undergraduates to play, I suppose.
So we have time for one more question.
Sorry. Yes, go ahead.
- [Ursula] Hi, my name is Ursula,
I'm also a computer science student here.
I was wondering if you had any things
that were top of mind,
relating to the intersection
of cybersecurity and generative AI
and is there something
that you think Amazon should be working on
that they aren't pursuing at the moment?
- Oh, so, I won't talk
about all our roadmap stuff
and there's a lot of work we are doing
that we'll bring out
in the course of time.
I think generative AI and cybersecurity,
cybersecurity I think will
get a lot more interesting
with generative AI, in two different ways.
One is bad actors can use generative AI
to create more of these threats.
More threats that compromise systems.
And so there's that aspect
where they now have a new set of tools.
Now there's the other aspect of it,
which is you can use AI in
general and generative AI also,
to be monitoring systems and
to be raising the barriers
to people getting in.
So I think there's both aspects of it
and I think there's work to be done,
including a lot of very
interesting research to be done
at the intersection of the two.
And I suspect there's a lot
of very interesting research
to be done there.
- Okay, great. So with that,
I'd like to thank our guest
Bratin Saha once again for coming
(audience applauding)
And I'd also like to thank our team,
for helping us put this together
and Tsai City for hosting us.
It's great to be able to run these here.
So, thanks very much once again sir.
- [Bratin] Thank you
Dean Brock. Thank you.
(pensive music)